donc ce qu'on voulait savoir le point de
vue des architectes et paysagistes on
avait déjà reçu en audition de façon
conjointe déjà les entreprises
d'architecture et paysagistes parce que
ça nous paraît dans les projets à être
quelque chose de de cohérent donc
doivent intervenir ainsi ça on doit
additionner Madame Valérie flicotto mais
qui arrivera
vice-présidente du Conseil national de
l'Ordre des architectes mais qui
arrivera avec un peu de retard madame
Goncalves architecte plasticienne et
cofondatrice du groupe seuil qu'on a en
visioconférence assez simple vous nous
entendez bonjour madame ah ben nous
aussi merci beaucoup
madame Juliette hunin donc délégué
général de la Fédération Française du
paysage
qui est donc l'association nationale
professionnelle des paysagistes
concepteurs accompagnés de Madame
Anne-Cécile Jacquot de Madame Edith
Valley et de Monsieur Dany Hermel Biard
tout le monde qui exerce sous les trois
donc le métier de paysagiste concepteur
donc
OK
donc voilà on attache beaucoup
d'importance ce serait à la mixité
du paysagistes et des architectes pour
penser aux aménagements surtout dans ces
périodes de canicule et de lutter contre
les effets induits et puis
donc je vous rappelle simplement que
cette audition fait l'objet d'un
captage vidéo dans un enregistrement est
accessible sur les sites du Sénat
donc
notre objectif c'est d'évaluer les
besoins de rénovation des écoles
collèges
et lycées liés à la transition
écologique mais aussi d'identifier les
défis notamment juridiques et financiers
de cette rénovation pour les
collectivités territoriales et donc
d'évaluer l'efficacité de
l'accompagnement des décideurs locaux
un questionnaire vous a été envoyé non
vous n'avez pas reçu de questionnaire
bon et bien comment les architectes oui
voilà pour que on puisse compléter
peut-être vos interventions par des
éléments écrits voudraient bien nous
transmettre à l'issue de
donc j'ai donné tout de suite la parole
à Gilbert Fabro donc qui à la mission de
rapporteur cet après-midi
moi j'étais également
je remplacais donc le rapporteur le
rapporteuse qui initialement à Nîmes
c'est ses auditions
je j'ai bien compris donc nous entendons
d'abord les deux personnes qui sont
actuellement à domicile ou comme quel
est l'ordre monsieur le président
on peut peut-être reprendre l'ordre
puisque madame philippoto est arrivé
c'est ça très bien
donc
intervention de
tout le monde paysagiste bon je résume
ça vient d'être fait par le président
donc le Sénat fait habituellement
[Musique]
des recherches sur des sujets qui sont
d'actualité et actuellement l'actualité
pour ce qui vous concerne c'est
précisément
certes tout ce qui concerne le bâti et
l'aménagement extérieur des collèges
mais c'est aussi la rénovation
énergétique qui qui est un problème
majeur qui est accentué par
le climat actuel et qui surtout est
accentué par la crise de l'énergie donc
nous avons dans ce cadre-là
la volonté de nous faire une idée de ce
que peuvent être les travaux des
architectes et des paysagistes sur des
bâtiments
qui généralement sont des bâtiments
anciens bon si on remonte un peu en
arrière on remonte à la décentralisation
puisqu'à l'époque c'était l'État qui
gérait tous ces établissements
aujourd'hui les différents degrés dans
cette bande chacun leur compétences les
écoles primaires sont du ressort des
communes ou des intercommunalités les
collèges sont des ressort des
départements et les lycées sont du
ressort du conseil régional donc tout ça
fait que les bâtiments qui ont été
transférés en propriété à ces
collectivités sont quelquefois en très
mauvais état et très souvent aussi il
faut reconstruire ces bâtiments donc je
vois un peu la ligne de question qui
m'est posée tout d'abord
on me
dit que dans les exemples qui ont été
constatées sur le terrain
les travaux qui abritent qui ont permis
de construire de nouveaux établissements
scolaires sont quelquefois inspirés
par le souhait de l'architecte de faire
quelque chose de nouveau et
d'agréables
pour ceux qui visitent les lieux mais
qui par contre n'ont pas toujours bien
que beaux gestes architecturaux
les qualités qu'on demande à un
établissement qui doit accueillir des
élèves et qui doit être
non seulement organisé de façon
rationnelle mais également très adapté à
l'enseignement
donc cette dichotomie entre la beauté du
geste et l'utilité
qui est celle du bâtiment autre chose
sur
les défis de la transition écologique la
question est de savoir mais vous ne
répondrez sans difficulté certainement
si vous avez été formés
à tout ce qui concerne donc
les travaux qui sont associés à la
transition écologique
on va pas les reprendre dans le détail
vous avez compris quel était cette
seconde question
même question pour les paysagistes
peut-être moins sur la transition
écologique encore que les variétés que
vous serez amené éventuellement à mettre
dans les jardins qui entourent ces
bâtiments bien doivent être eux aussi
adaptés parce qu'il y a là aussi des
évolutions et puis dernier point et
j'aurais moi pour ma part terminer ma
présentation le guide
qui s'intitule mère et architecte dix
clés pour réussir la transition
écologique qui est celui-ci et qui est
donc disponible sur le conseil sur le
site du Conseil national de l'Ordre des
architectes
est-ce que vous êtes au courant de
l'origine de cette publication donc
quelles conditions a-t-elle été élaborée
existe donc existe-t-il d'autres
documents similaires
ce type de dés les professionnels de
l'architecture et du paysage voilà alors
donc si je repasse la parole au
président qui va probablement vous
demander à
présenter donc Céline Brunin et
Véronique del fabreau qui sont natrices
c'est pour mettre un petit peu de parité
dans cette audition
bien que de votre côté
elles sont un petit peu biaisées malgré
bien donc on va peut-être commencer à
vous avez pas de qui sont particulières
on aura après dans le débat peut-être
vous donner voilà un temps qu'on
limitera peut-être à 10 minutes
d'intervention chacune pour qu'on puisse
ensuite
échanger vous avez reçu la liste de
questions qui étaient posées voilà vous
pouvez
vous en servir comme trame ou en tout
cas nous faire une présentation et puis
éventuellement nous transmettre à
préparer des réponses aussi des choses
n'ont pas été abordées donc Madame
Picotto vous donne la parole
merci monsieur le Président et merci de
d'avoir
d'auditionner le conseil de l'or sur ce
sujet qui est éminemment important et
effectivement très stratégique pour nous
je sais pas si comme le temps est court
je vais peut-être pas vous représenter
l'ordre on a des éléments qui qui
pourront vous le présenter juste
rapidement il y a 30 000 architectes en
France répartis sur l'ensemble du
territoire et il y a un conseil national
qui coordonne des conseils régionaux
donc il y a bien une représentation de
l'Ordre des architectes par région pour
rentrer plus dans le vif du sujet
et particulièrement sur les questions de
rénovation avant peut-être de parler
plus de construction mais sur la
question de la rénovation des bâtiments
scolaires
ce qu'on a un petit peu envie de dire
est-ce qu'on a un peu envie de porter
c'est l'idée que finalement il faut pas
cantonner ces interventions de
rénovation sur le bâti scolaire à
uniquement le prisme de rénovation
thermique mais utilisez ce moment qui
est un moment important pour intégrer
d'autres paramètres qui sont déjà
améliorés le confort d'usage vous
parliez tout à l'heure de bâtiments qui
sont peut-être malades adaptées au
profit d'un risque d'un geste
architectural alors vous m'envoyez assez
peiné parce que si vous voulez répondre
à une commande d'architecte c'est bien
notamment en prioritairement répondre à
la question de l'usage et de et de du
confort des usagers donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui guide a priori
l'intervention de l'architecte mais du
coup ce travail de mise à niveau
environnemental du bâtiment à l'occasion
de sa rénovation thermique ça peut
justement être aussi l'occasion de
d'avoir des gestes correctifs et aussi
de travailler sur quelque chose qui
était
qui était un petit peu occultée et
notamment
sur tous les collèges et lycées qui ont
été faits après les années 50-60 où il y
a peut-être eu pas mal de préfabriqués
ou ce genre de choses c'est travailler à
la question de la du confort d'hiver du
confort d'été qui aujourd'hui est
devient de plus en plus prégnant
notamment dans un moment de transition
de transition environnementale où on
sait que
à 2050 on attend 20 jours de canicule
mortelle par an quand même donc la
question du confort d'été est de plus en
plus prégnant va monter de plus en plus
en en puissance donc le sujet et cette
question du confort d'été est très mal
pris en compte dans la réglementation
telle qu'elle est pratiquée aujourd'hui
en rénovation la réglementation
environnementale qui s'applique
aujourd'hui sur les bâtiments neufs la
re2020 l intègre ces problématiques de
conformité et d'approche bas carbone
à contrario pour la rénovation on reste
sur une réglementation thermique 2012
qui est en retrait et qui ne parle pas
du tout de confort d'été alors que on
sait que la question du confort d'été
sera quand même la question de demain
vous dire aussi que par rapport à ça
du coup
[Musique]
nous on encourage aussi dans ces
rénovations à privilégier
à ce à s'approcher à des solutions
techniques qui sont plutôt des solutions
techniques du low tech avec pas beaucoup
d'entretien pas beaucoup de systèmes
justement parce que on sait que et vous
vous en parliez en introduction que les
bâtiments scolaires surtout quand ils
sont
pris en charge par des petites
collectivités ont pas forcément des
organismes de maintenance des équipes
Haddock en capacité d'assurer une
maintenance continu surtout qu'on sait
que c'est des équipements qui sont très
sollicités donc privilégier des choses
plutôt robuste et avec peu de
maintenance avec des systèmes low tech
privilégiés des je sais pas moi des des
occultations fixes plutôt que que
d'avoir des choses qui se qui se
régulent par des
choses manuelles plutôt que des choses
électriques
éviter des systèmes de ventilation
double flux qui demande beaucoup de
maintenance avec avec beaucoup de
changements de filtres avec tout ça donc
ça c'est des sujets sur lequel nous on
travaille et on a on a fait un petit un
petit travail qui s'appelle justement
rénover low tech donc sur cette question
de comment
aborder la question de la rénovation
avec le moins de systèmes possibles
on invite aussi le législateur
à privilégier plutôt
pas s'orienter vers des contrats globaux
pour pour ces rénovations mais plutôt à
privilégier des contrats en lot séparés
notamment parce que
ça permet d'avoir une maîtrise d'oeuvre
un contrat de maîtrise d'oeuvre qui est
adapté à la situation et qui portera un
regard qui sera justement
vraiment
pas systématique si vous voulez donc ce
sera vraiment un regard particulier
adapté avec un diagnostic patrimonial et
architectural qui sera vraiment
dédié au bâtiment pour éviter des
solutions techniques toutes faites je
sais que en ce moment on parle beaucoup
de hors site on entend parler d'énergie
sprong on entend parler de ce type de
solution qui sont faites par assemblage
avec des solutions techniques mais
avec la crainte que ça enferme un petit
peu l'évolution des bâtiments et que
finalement même sur sur deux bâtiments
qui sont similaires même année
construction mais dans des communes
différents la question même sociale se
pose différemment de la rénovation et
l'intérêt d'avoir une une rénovation qui
est sur mesure avec une maîtrise
d'oeuvre dédiée à chaque fois c'est
aussi se reposer toutes ces questions
qui sont bien au-delà de du strictement
de l'énergie c'est des caissons d'usage
c'est des questions de vie c'est
d'utiliser l'ensemble de l'environnement
du bâtiment aussi pour en faire un un
outil de la conception bioclimatique je
pense au rafraîchissement dans les cours
d'école aux abords à tout ce qui est
aussi gestion du nom plus durable
et avec des assainissements mais je
pense que ça les paysagistes vous
parleront de tous ces sujets là
donc il y a
cette question qui est extrêmement forte
et importante on sait aussi que tout ce
qui est
équipement public en général et vous le
disiez impact directement la question du
patrimoine et de la qualité patrimoniale
du bâti
on a bien sûr en tête les lycées Jules
Ferry les écoles communales de chaque
village et là encore
ça
demande de porter un regard particulier
et qui est d'installer aussi un
dialogue un petit peu décalé notamment
avec l'architecte des bâtiments de
France autour de ces questions de
préservation patrimoniale
et qui est facilité
encore une fois par une maîtrise
d'oeuvre sur mesure
c'est voilà assez rapidement et alors
autre chose aussi
par rapport à cette question de alors là
je me décale plutôt sur des sujets de
construction
en relation avec la question du bas
carbone et d'un aménagement urbain qui
lui serait décarbonée en fait on observe
et particulièrement pour les collèges
que finalement cette gestion un peu
séparée de
des collèges par les départements des
moins pour les écoles primaires qui sont
sur le patrimoine communal mais entre
les collèges et les lycées ça ça amène
des implantations de bâtiments qui sont
plutôt attachés des espèces
d'opportunités foncières
liées à la problématique du département
à ce moment-là ou à la problématique de
la région mais pas du tout dans une
vision d'aménagement du territoire
global et notamment de ménagement des
mobilité
douce et
des carbonées
dit plus
plus pragmatiquement on met des collèges
peut-être loin des villes ou un des
centres-villes on qui implique d'avoir
des desserts par bus scolaire qui
empêche les élèves de se rendre en vélo
ou à pied dans leur établissement et qui
induisent du coup des déplacements qui
pourraient être certainement limitées
voire supprimer si cette question de la
localisation du foncier était mieux
anticipée et mieux coordonner à
l'intérieur d'une vision d'aménagement
du territoire global et de stratégie
vis-à-vis de la commune et dernier point
on incite aussi le législateur à mettre
en place une mission et un observatoire
de l'état du bâti scolaire
qui permet aussi
là encore toujours dans une vision d'une
planification de la transition
écologique
d'avoir une vision stratégique pour
accompagner commune où les collectivités
territoriales
sur comment engager les travaux et donc
prioriser les bâtiments qui souffrent le
plus soit de confort d'été je pense
plutôt dans le sud soit de confort
d'hiver et de pouvoir s'attaquer de
façon prioritaire au bâtiment qui en ont
le plus besoin
ce qui permettra
du coup
à l'ensemble de la filière y compris des
entreprises de travaux à savoir où
mettre l'énergie à quel moment et sur
quel territoire
donc ça aussi cette espèce de cette
vision stratégique elle est pour nous
extrêmement importante et pour répondre
aussi à votre à votre question sur la
question de des personnels enfin des
architectes on n'a pas de problème sur
la compétence des architectes parce que
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
intégré et d'un point de vue de la
formation initiale dans les écoles c'est
un sujet qui qui est
qui a intégré la formation initiale
alors avec un peu de retard mais qui
maintenant est en train de rattraper son
retard et de la même façon la formation
continue des architectes le nombre de
formations qui touche à ces sujets se
développent de plus en plus en fait
j'étais en retard parce que j'étais sur
une formation dédiée à la question d'un
ventilation naturelle dans le bâtiment
donc c'est aussi des choses qui
impactent directement la question
d'information donc nous notre sujet
c'est pas tant la compétence des
architectes mais plutôt la crainte de
voir se créer des déserts architecturaux
puisque
on fait tous les deux ans on a un
observatoire de l'état de la profession
qui s'appelle archigraphie et on a fait
un focus là justement sur les questions
de démographie et on se rend compte que
les architectes boomers sont en train de
partir à la retraite et que dans
certains territoires quand il y a que 13
architectes dans la Creuse et que on
voit pas de personnes qui vont venir
s'installer ça va on pense que ça va
poser des problèmes et notamment
justement par rapport à l'accompagnement
des des communes rurales qui ont en
charge les écoles et c'est pour ça que
on est en train de travailler un
dispositif qui s'appelle un architecte
justement pour avec l'espoir peut-être
de trouver des dispositifs d'aide à
l'installation dans les territoires
ruraux et je n'ai pas sur moi mais on
vous fera parvenir sans
délai d'autres documents notamment on a
écrit un plaidoyer qui s'appelle ville
territoire habitat l'architecture comme
solution parce que on voit justement que
dans toutes ces questions de transition
l'architecture apporte des solutions
notamment aussi sur les questions de bas
carbone autour de la prescription de
matériaux biosourcés géosourcés des
matériaux de réemploi qui peuvent être
aussi
facteurs de développement de filière
locale
donc là encore avec des boucles
justement d'une stratégie locale pour
faire monter en puissance
ces questions et puis d'avoir une
approche qui est adaptée au climat et à
la région de chaque territoire et donc
là encore pas de solution sur mesure et
dans le dispositif un architecte on a un
petit peu revu tous nos contrats
notamment les contrats de conseil pour
pour amener les architectes à travailler
sur des sujets de ce conseil et de
stratégie être en capacité de faire des
plans guides pour les communes justement
pour pour apporter cette vision
d'aménagement du territoire et d'un
aménagement du territoire stratégique
pour savoir par où commencer et comment
aussi accompagner je reviens à cette
question de l'implantation du collège au
bon endroit
et alors les CAE sont aussi là mais je
veux dire il y a 36 000 communes
donc c'est une tâche qui est extrêmement
importante et bien sûr ce dispositif ma
mère un architecte il se fera pas sans
laisser aie et sans cette question du
conseil
avec eux évidemment
[Musique]
allô non là on vous entend plus tout à
l'heure c'était parfait
est-ce que vous avez mis le son vous
nous rendez
parfait merci beaucoup merci monsieur le
Président
donc je vais prendre quand même quelques
minutes pour me présenter laisse-lui bon
salvès je suis architecte je suis
co-fondatrice du groupe seuil qui
comprend trois sociétés à missions
on ingénierie et la réalisation
nous avons une sensibilité
co-responsable
participative et régénérative
et notre société d'architecture existe
depuis 2005
je voulais préciser que je même si nous
réalisons des groupes scolaires des
collèges et des lycées nous ne sommes
pas spécialisés dans l'enseignement on a
on est plutôt des généralistes on fait
aussi des usines des bureaux du logement
de l'urbanisme de l'habitat voilà un
certain nombre de sujets
je voulais aussi vous dire que j'étais
vraiment ravie de participer à cette à
cette tour de table et d'y prendre part
donc pour un petit peu démarrer la
préparation de cette table ronde je
voulais revenir sur tout simplement
l'intitulé qui m'a été transmis
je lis le bâti scolaire à l'épreuve de
la transition écologique
et pour moi le mot épreuve est une
plutôt une dimension négative qui met un
doute et donc presque je vous pourrez
vous proposer de un nouveau titre qui
serait la transition écologique
l'opportunité pour le bâtiment scolaire
pour moi ça serait de déplacer le focus
et de voir en quoi cette transition
écologique va énormément apporter que ce
soit dans les territoires ruraux les
territoires urbains je n'ai pas le
contexte qui est effectivement assez
délicat et difficile en ce moment donc
nous notre groupe est installé sur
Toulouse et sur Montpellier donc on est
sur la région plutôt Occitanie et
effectivement la région Occitanie
recense en ce moment une augmentation
claire de du coût de l'énergie avec
parfois dans certains lycées les
factures électriques ont été multipliées
par 4 donc il y a urgence effectivement
et
pour moi l'urgence c'est genre
rejoindrai ma conso Valérie Picotto qui
a dit de pas se cantonner aux prismes de
la rénovation thermique
effectivement d'envisager cette
rénovation thermique des bâtiments c'est
rénovation manière beaucoup plus large
pour pouvoir investir dans les vins à 30
prochaines années pour pouvoir investir
200 à pouvoir faire des groupes
scolaires qui correspondent aux besoins
aux usages pour les 30 prochaines années
et je sais et je
ressens cette l'importance des groupes
scolaires pour
pour les élus pour le Sénat c'est
véritablement un acte politique et il
faut qu'on soit effectivement les
architectes autour de la table pour
pouvoir vous indiquer en quoi la
rénovation énergétique
effectivement au-delà de l'enveloppe du
bâtiment et au-delà de des énergies
renouvelables finalement doit être
accompagné par les concepteurs et je
suis ravie et donc j'avais aussi
indiqué que pour nous les paysagistes
devaient être autour de la table pour
qu'on échange ensemble parce que nous
sommes vraiment très complémentaires
alors moi je voulais vous faire en clair
j'ai réfléchi à quelque chose de pour
essayer de vous indiquer de formuler
quelque chose qui serait
retenable trois grandes propositions
trois grands axes le premier ça serait
de d'avoir une démarche vraiment
contextuelle participative
travailler énormément sur la stabilité
donc en fait dans notre structure nous
faisons aussi de la co-construction des
ateliers participatifs on est énormément
dans cette démarche et ce que je peux
vous assurer c'est qu'avec un retour
d'expérience de presque 20 ans c'est que
les projets que l'on réalise on n'a pas
la boule au ventre quand on doit les
livrer on est vraiment au contraire dans
une idée de déco responsabilités
communes et partagée ou l'ensemble des
acteurs sont autour de la table et on
prend le temps avec les élus avec
les péd agogies
[Musique]
le l'enseignant les bureaux d'études les
paysagistes bien sûr les enfants des de
concevoir d'avoir des
des programmes bien identifiés mais
aussi derrière des projets pour les
réaliser de manière concrète
alors je voulais par exemple
identifier pour moi qu'il est important
de ne pas forcément construire
massivement des extensions de façon
industrielle qui ferait fit vraiment des
problématiques locales mais bien au
contraire d'imaginer
à chaque fois un projet bien adapté donc
pour que ce soit peut-être plus plus
lisible et plus compréhensible nous
avons eu un cas particulier pour un
collège où nous avons réalisé en fait
une visite et on nous a demandé de
réaliser une extension
donc on fait la visite et on se rend
compte à ce moment-là que les usagers
finalement se retrouvent dans un
bâtiment très grand pas forcément adapté
en fait les extensions qui ont été
multiples tous les changements qui ont
été faits font que les espaces sont
parfois très grands mal éclairés et que
oui il faut faire une extension mais
peut-être en repensant avec le bâtiment
existant si on ne se contente pas que à
l'enveloppe et à l'énergie on réfléchit
aussi sur les usages et finalement on va
pouvoir construire peut-être moins mais
mieux et en repensant aussi les pièces
et les lieux existants grâce aux
échanges pédagogiques et du coup on se
retrouve pas dans le cas où on aurait
par exemple une équipe pédagogique qui
serait dans le bâtiment neuf bien rénové
nouveau et l'autre un peu juste eu un
coup de peinture donc voilà en gros pour
nous pour nous pour notre groupe pour
vous pour les élus on est persuadé que
finalement co-construire avec les
utilisateurs c'est permettre aux élus
demain d'être au plus près de
véritablement de sa population de ses
citoyens et d'être en véritable relation
et d'offrir un service pédagogique de
haute qualité
le deuxième point pour moi qui est très
important c'est on en a parlé c'est la
question de la matérialité effectivement
travailler avec des matériaux biosourcés
géosées avec du réemploi
c'est vraiment pour nous une obligation
et c'est vraiment l'avenir c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui quand on va construire
avec isolant à base d'herbe c'est un
isolant qu'on va récupérer sur les bords
des routes c'est aujourd'hui c'est très
bien industrialisé les éléments
d'isolation est très et de très bonne
qualité ça veut dire qu'on est plutôt
dans un processus finalement qui demande
très peu d'énergie bas carbone c'est un
matériau après derrière qui peut tout
simplement être
recyclé même mis au sol on a déjà fait
des bâtiments en bois et en paille la
paille en fait on l'a la réponse au sol
et elle va elle va se recomposer donc
c'est c'est très efficace
on travaille aussi énormément avec
effectivement la terre crue on a parlé
du confort d'été bien sûr il faut
accompagner le confort d'été avec la
question de l'enveloppe du bâtiment qui
nécessite avec les architectes et les
ingénieurs une belle connaissance de la
rénovation avec tous tes problématiques
de qualité de l'air de ventilation
naturelle de perspirance de ne pas
piéger l'eau la qualité de l'air donc
beaucoup de sujets mais par exemple la
terre crue peut apporter aussi de
l'inertie c'est un matériau qu'on
retrouve énormément sur le Bassin
parisien
on ça matériau qui est très facilement
réparable qui nécessite très peu d'eau
très peu d'énergie donc c'est ça on l'a
dit tout à l'heure l'idée c'est d'aller
chercher des matériaux qui vont demander
peu d'énergie et qui vont aussi
développer des savoir-faire
par exemple dans le cas de la terre crue
même si par exemple les violons
biosourcés le bois ça va être plutôt de
la compétence des charpentiers les
maçons vont pouvoir se réapparaît des
savoir-faire locaux en réalisant et en
maçonnant de la terre crue et donc là on
arrive sur aussi des métiers que l'on
veut qualifie et qui sont vraiment
valorisés un autre point sur les
matériaux c'est leur emploi nous
développons énormément la filière de
rien pour l'Occitanie sachez que sur
Toulouse nous n'avons pas encore de
plateformes de stockage du réemploi sur
la région de Montpellier ça démarre donc
on se mobilisait énormément le réemploi
c'est quoi c'est un outil formidable
pour vous il faut vous en emparer
aujourd'hui nous avons énormément de
patrimoine soit à rénover soit à démolir
aujourd'hui on proscrit le mot et le
terme démolir et on déconstruit
l'objectif c'est quoi c'est tout
simplement de récupérer des équipements
par exemple donc ça peut être des
chemins de câble qui sont quasiment
neufs
des fenêtres des portes des menuiseries
en fait c'est d'établir des diagnostics
et à partir de cette diagnostic de voir
qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir réintroduire
dans des bâtiments même neufs c'est ce
qu'on fait dans un collège à
Castelnau-d'Estrétefonds où on
réintroduit par exemple un parquet
massif en chêne et tous les lots sont
sensibilisés à ce type de
procédure alors par rapport à tous ces
éléments quelques freins malgré tout
des freins oui sur la réglementation et
la normalisation française aujourd'hui
il faut dire que les bureaux de contrôle
la plupart et les assureurs sont autour
de la table et on commence à créer des
relations avec des discussions qui font
qu'on arrive facilement et de mieux en
mieux à réaliser ce type d'opération
c'est quand même parfois relativement
compliqué lorsqu'on a fait le collège
Castelnau-d'Estrétefonds mais le
réemploi tout simplement le l'outil pour
lancer l'appel d'offre n'était pas
adaptée à ce type de consultation il a
donc fallu qu'on fabrique un système
un peu
simplifié on va dire et pas tout à fait
optimum pour ce type d'opération donc on
a véritablement besoin du législateur
pour lever tous ces freins et aller plus
loin dans dans les frères réglementaires
les athèques la normalisation aller plus
loin dans la mise en oeuvre de ces de
tous ces matériaux
je voudrais aussi faire un tout petit
aparté avant de aller sur mon troisième
point c'est la question de la rénovation
qui est fondamentale votre sujet est
pertinent c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
oui il faut construire la ville sur
elle-même il faut rénover donc vous êtes
vraiment sur le juste
une information c'est qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons réalisé trois structures et
notamment une société de promotion
immobilière parce qu'on se rendait
compte que les
la promotion avait du mal à aller vers
des projets vertueux tels que nous on
les aime magie quand même impact positif
sobre sensible et en fait ils sont
confrontés à finalement des choses très
terre à terre il faut que vous puissiez
nous aider à lever comme par exemple
nous on a réalisé une opération de
réhabilitation de logement et bien en
fait on a quasiment pas trouvé de vente
on n'a pas trouvé de vente en tout cas
VTT bande ne nous a pas suivi pour
pouvoir faire des prêts avec non pas du
vire en neuf mais avec de la rénovation
donc avec un système plutôt vire et
avoir une GFA dans ce contexte là et
très difficile donc sachez que quand on
peut faire de la rénovation de
l'écologie de l'environnement et de la
transition écologique on se retrouve
confronté à des difficultés et c'est ces
freins là qu'il faut arriver à lever
pour que la profession soit en capacité
de vraiment répondre et aller dans votre
sens et le troisième point c'est je
pense que je vais rejoindre en tout cas
ceux qui sont autour de la table et qui
sont pour nous
vraiment notre binôme ce sont nos
confrères écologues et paysagistes sans
qui on ne peut pas réaliser les projets
de demain c'est à dire que c'est bien de
travailler de manière participative
revoir l'habitabilité de travailler dans
le contexte c'est très bien avec les
matériaux de limiter nos impacts
mais en fait il faut qu'on soit
aujourd'hui ça ne suffit plus il faut
qu'on soit sur une dimension au
contraire positive et cette dimension
positive pour nous c'est la régénération
des milieux c'est la préservation du sol
c'est en fait dans le couple écologue
arch paysagiste architecte c'est laisser
les écologues et les paysagistes
travailler marcher le lieu avec nous
mais bien sûr leur laisser le temps de
nous donner finalement l'étude d'impact
du site avant de mettre un premier coup
de crayon travailler de sorte à
favoriser la biodiversité favoriser en
fait tout un site qui va permettre
derrière
d'apporter des aménités la nature
d'apporter un bénéfice et donc nous
c'est ce que l'on fait par exemple pour
le lycée Bourdel qui est le lycée le
plus grand le plus important de
l'Académie toulousaine où on travaille
avec un paysagiste et où en fait sur une
cour enrobé de plus de 13 mm carré on
est en train de réaliser une
agroforesterie pour que les enfants
puissent être au frais et souvent
vraiment dans les meilleures capacités
pour pouvoir travailler donc en gros
voilà les trois points qui pour moi sont
très importants une démarche
participative une éco-responsabilité et
la régénération des milieux merci
beaucoup et merci de nous avoir fait la
transition pour l'intervention de nos
écologues paysagistes merci je leur
donne la parole alors
merci merci monsieur le Président merci
de nous avoir convié à cette mission sur
le bâti scolaire donc la FFP
représente est l'association nationale
des paysagistes concepteurs aujourd'hui
600 adhérents sur une profession qui est
plus jeune que nos collègues architectes
mais 4500 paysagistes concepteurs
aujourd'hui en France
nous vous proposons avec le document que
quand vous a fait parvenir de vous
présenter
trois paysagistes concepteurs trois
approches différentes sur la rénovation
et l'aménagement des cours scolaires
donc les cours c'est vrai c'est on est
sur des problématiques partagées par
rapport aux architectes mais un prisme
un peu plus large et on est au cœur là
vraiment de la transition et des
solutions concrètes sur cette transition
écologique donc je donne la parole à
dernière qui est paysagiste concepteur
de l'agence Trouillot Hermel paysage à
Bordeaux
merci Juliette merci monsieur le
président
oui en effet je là je vais intervenir
pour parler un petit peu de retour
d'expérience que j'ai avec mon avec la
ville de Bordeaux sur l'assistance à
maîtrise d'ouvrage pour le développement
des cours bissonnières à Bordeaux un
programme sur 4 ans de réhabilitation de
cours d'école en effet penser la
rénovation du bâti c'est aussi penser au
traitement de la cour d'école les
extérieurs les espaces extérieurs et en
cela tout à fait le paysagiste est
totalement dans sa légitimités par
rapport à ses compétences puisqu'il est
en mesure de moi il a une connaissance
du vivant connaissance aussi il s'est à
l'Isla avec les usages de la cour les
espaces des espaces extérieurs et il est
aussi capable de d'instaurer un dialogue
avec les différents usagers
on connaît tous bals contexte le contact
le constat actuel des cours d'école on a
tous cette en tête ces cours en enrobés
avec quelques arbres marronniers platane
du palais de végétal assez pauvre qui
est correspondait plus à des une
fonctionnalité quoi facile à entretenir
et puis pouvoir caser un maximum
d'enfants au même endroit avec le
terrain de sport au centre et puis du
coup les problématiques d'inclusion de
voilà de jeunes qui ne sait qui trouve
pas forcément leur place dans ce genre
de milieu
donc rafraîchir ces cours d'école pour
rafraîchir ses cours d'école il faut
avant tout penser à décrouter en fait ce
sol retrouvé ce le sol qu'il y a sous
cette sous cet enrobé donc ce travail de
découpage en effet la revitalisation des
sols et la clé de rafraîchissement de
nos villes car c'est dans ce sol que
qu'il y a une activité organique
biologique une aération qui permet
d'avoir une une rétention des eaux
pluviales et voilà il a vraiment cette
fonction faire il a un rôle d'éponge
dans la ville dans nos sols et il permet
également de stocker le carbone donc
vraiment il a la restauration de ses
sols à notre sens vraiment l'enjeu
principal de pour travailler sur
rafraîchissement
l'autre enjeu aussi c'est le rapport à
la nature il s'agit en effet de remettre
l'enfant au contact de la nature vous
l'avez bien compris parce que c'est pour
lui permettre d'apprendre à la connaître
et la respecter puisque bah ces milieux
dont je vous ai parlé précédemment la
cour en enrobé c'est vrai que n'est pas
très épanouissante et ne pas connaître
son environnement comment demander à des
enfants de le respecter de voilà de
quand on voit un arbre forcément les
voix malmenées dans les cours d'école ça
va pas vouloir aux enfants et c'est un
mobilier comme un autre pour eux
malheureusement et c'est là-dessus qu'il
faut changer un peu les paradigmes
donc la cour d'école pour nous c'est
aussi un lieu propice à l'éveil à la
sociabilisation à la santé et aussi au
développement de la biodiversité sachant
que je mets je tiens quand même à
souligner la biodiversité dans les cours
d'école ok mais
l'usage de ses cours il faut pas comment
dire c'est un milieu qui a qui reste
fragile puisque c'est un milieu vivant
un autre enjeu de la cour d'école c'est
le rapport le rapport au temps
la végétalisation des cours d'école doit
prendre le temps considération puisqu'il
y a en effet avant tout le temps de la
conception le temps des travaux et c'est
pour cela je précise en général quand on
travaille sur les cours d'école dans la
réhabilitation il y a deux mois une
petite fenêtre de tir de 2 mois et des
fois un mois si on est sur des crèches
ou si on est sur des du périscolaire des
fois les écoles sont ouvertes l'été donc
un mois ou deux pour faire les travaux
vers des très souvent et la
végétalisation on essaie de la repousser
pour les périodes favorables aux
plantations à la Toussaint ou alors en
hiver
enfin l'un des derniers enjeux voilà de
cette restauration des cours d'école
c'est la concertation
une courbisonnière pour nous ça se
construit c'est ce qui a été dit
d'ailleurs précédemment ça se co
construit avec les équipes pédagogiques
les élèves les agents des services les
associations les périscolaires voilà etc
les élèves aussi eux-mêmes donc vraiment
il y a beaucoup d'acteurs et c'est là
encore que le paysagiste à son à son
rôle à jouer de pouvoir sensibiliser de
pouvoir observer et d'expérimenter avec
eux
face à ma grâce à cette expérience que
nous avons eu on a pu relever quand même
des problématiques mais aussi des
potentialités sur le traitement de ses
cours d'école en premier lieu je tiens à
souligner vraiment à tirer votre
attention sur l'importance des
diagnostics qui doivent être faits au
préalable lorsqu'on travaille sur sur
une cour d'école les diagnostics
notamment
complet sur la réflexion des réseaux
histoire de ne pas avoir réouvrir les
sols après j'en parle en connaissance de
cause puisque très souvent on a des
problèmes de planning même pour la
rénovation d'un bâtiment il s'agit de
faire les choses dans l'ordre quand on
doit réintervenir sur une façade quand
on a végétalisé les pieds de bâtiment
c'est un sujet comme très très compliqué
il y a les tests de perméabilité
également à mettre en prenant
considération puisque des
imperméabilisés c'est bien mais
permettre à l'autre s'infiltrer c'est
mieux
on a aussi relevé les limites de la
végétalisation
à savoir que le végétal il n'a pas
forcément vocation à résoudre les
problèmes de surchauffe de bâtiment
n'oublions pas que le végétal c'est
vivant ça se plante jeune il faut qu'il
s'installe dans le sol si on veut créer
de l'ombrage même avec des pergolas ou
bien en créer une structure qui apporte
de l'ombre mais si l'on veut vraiment
que la les fonds des arbres apportent de
la fraîcheur que les plantes grimpantes
aussi apportent de la fraîcheur ça ne se
fera pas à la plantation
et là encore c'est l'autre point sur
lequel je voudrais assister sur les sur
les potentialités et les problématiques
c'est la cour d'école on propose des
solutions au long cours à savoir que on
ne réalise pas une cour d'école en six
mois puisque nous comme je vous disais
il y a les différents temps il y a aussi
le temps de la concertation travaux etc
il faut aussi accompagner les nouveaux
usagers les nouveaux usages puisqu'on va
transformer cette cour donc quelle est
va être le rapport avec l'enfant mais
aussi les enseignants sur ce nouveau
support pédagogique le vivant la nature
donc il y a des habitudes des habitudes
à prendre des règles à fixer à Bordeaux
notamment on a travaillé sur des chartes
d'usage et ensuite c'est en
responsabilise également puisqu'on livre
quelque chose un produit vivant si je
puis dire
d'école est censée prendre vie mais
c'est des êtres vivants que dont il faut
prendre soin arroser qu'est-ce que l'on
fait l'été qu'est-ce que l'on fait voilà
comment est-ce qu'on on gère cet espace
comment on valorise aussi ces espaces
je vous propose de passer la parole à
Edith Valais sur qui a relevé tous les
défis techniques qu'on imagine pas
forcément dans réaménagement de d'une
cour d'école
alors on va prendre la slide alors
effectivement la question de la
réalisation du chantier voilà on va on
va rentrer un petit peu dans les points
importants les défis techniques qu'on en
a identifié 5 ils sont très importants
d'abord parce qu'effectivement comme la
souligne Dany on a des fenêtres de tir
pour faire les travaux qui sont
extrêmement courts et on touche la
plupart du temps quand on travaille en
profondeur sur la question de
l'infiltration à des travaux qui
s'apparentent au génie civil or sur deux
mois effectivement de travaux en
juillet-août avec des difficultés aussi
de climat etc ce sont des travaux
extrêmement importants donc il faut
prendre la mesure là vous avez un
exemple effectivement avec la création
une destruction de bassins de rétention
existants au profit d'un bassin
d'infiltration créé pour limiter tous
les rejets et aussi récupérer l'eau dans
une cuve d'arrosage
et le réseau complet du de drainage qui
accompagne ses travaux donc à relever
des travaux extrêmement lourds et
importants qui nécessitent une
mobilisation du côté de la maîtrise
d'oeuvre et du côté des entreprises ce
type de travaux pour vous donner un
ordre d'idée à nécessiter sur 2,8 de
travaux d'entreprise voilà donc il faut
que tout ça tous ces paramètres là soit
bien en phase
ensuite deuxième chose alors une fois
qu'on a fait tout ce sol favorable à
l'infiltration il faut choisir le bon
vêtement alors le bon vêtement il faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui les sols drainants
sont encore en phase d'expérimentation
on a encore en face de recherche et
développement sur un certain nombre de
matériaux dont le béton dont
effectivement les sols en résine
poreuses donc on travaille aussi voilà
en relation avec les fournisseurs pour
adapter nos procédés
là vous avez effectivement une des
exemples de sous-couche et de couches de
revêtement il faut savoir que comme les
architectes soulignent on est aussi à
même de faire du recyclage quand
effectivement les sous-couches des sols
peuvent être conservées on le fait et
puis on peut aller aussi vers des
solutions de fraisa d'enrobés ou de
béton qui permettent de recycler une
série des matériaux en gardant des
propriétés de perméabilité
alors le défi de l'eau bien sûr
puisqu'il est question effectivement de
collecter cette eau de la renvoyer à la
nappe ou effectivement de la mettre au
jour sur un plan didactique c'est à dire
qu'il est question aussi pour faire
mesurer aux élèves aux enfants la
précurité de cette eau c'est aussi la
mettre au jour et favoriser des réseaux
à ciel ouvert voilà alors c'est pas
toujours le cas et pas toujours possible
dans le cas des usages néanmoins quand
on peut le faire c'est aussi un des
leviers
déficience de ces systèmes sur le plan
effectivement de la pédagogie il faut
savoir aussi que les réseaux à ciel
ouvert sont moins
propres à créer de la maintenance lourde
de réseau enterré
alors rafraîchir alors plusieurs axes
bien évidemment les plantations alors on
en a mis les limites par rapport au
développement de la végétation qui est
long néanmoins ce sont nos arbres sont
les premiers climatiseurs qui apportent
à la fois de l'ombrage et
produisent de la brume effectivement qui
rafraîchissent ça peut être évidemment
les structures couvertes hypergola donc
là vous avez un exemple de recyclage
d'un préau sur lequel on a adjoint une
pergola neuve et avec un système à terme
de plantes grimpantes qui offriront des
solutions d'ombrage et dernier point les
voiles d'ombrage ou toutes les
structures voilà comme des grands
parapluies ou des grands parasols qui
permettent un de rafraîchir
effectivement le climat à l'intérieur de
la cour et permettre aussi la classe en
plein air qui font partie effectivement
des commandes et des programmes de ces
cours ces fameuses cours dit oasis ou
cours îlot de fraîcheur
voilà et puis dernier point on a parlé
sur l'eau une fois qu'effectivement là
on l'a récupéré on la stocke et on
l'utilise intelligemment pour l'arrosage
automatique donc au moyen de cuve voilà
plus ou moins dimensionnés et qui
peuvent arroser aussi des espaces très
fragiles comme les potagers donc là vous
avez un exemple où on n'a pas pu se
passer d'un réseau d'arrosage
automatique connecté sur les eaux
pluviales parce que l'absence de
personnel d'entretien les mois d'été
font qu'effectivement un potager sans
personnel ne marche pas
voilà
juste je me permets de souligner que
pour tous ces défis techniques on est
aussi accompagné très fortement sur les
territoires par les agences de l'eau qui
sont quand même des des appuis
extrêmement précieux bien sûr
financièrement mais aussi surtout de
leur accompagnement technique de tous
les dossiers et ça c'est vraiment un
appui très fort le dernier enfin le
troisième point qu'on voulait aussi
appuyer bien sûr c'est la concertation
et cette cour d'école elle est le
premier espace qu'on habite c'est le
premier espace où on expérimente
l'altérité où on découvre l'autre où on
est on entre dans le jeu social aussi et
où on découvre aussi tous les enjeux qui
sont autour de la place des garçons des
filles etc comment cette répartition des
usages et des habitudes peut se faire et
au-delà même de la végétalisation des
cours d'école et de la
désimpermabilisation il y a bien sûr
aussi cette intention que nous avons de
vouloir aussi trouver des solutions pour
améliorer aussi les rapports entre les
enfants les rapports entre les enfants
et les adultes donc notre mission dans
la transformation de ces cours d'école
c'est bien sûr de sensibiliser de quoi
concevoir avec les enfants mais aussi
les services techniques qu'ils soient
associés le au plus le plus en amont
possible des démarches donc via des
ateliers facilitation de groupe
présentation des matériaux
sensibilisation autour du cycle de l'eau
etc
c'est aussi l'occasion bien sûr de de
répondre une fois qu'on a l'ensemble de
ces contraintes techniques notre travail
de paysagiste c'est bien de concevoir
des cours qui répondent à leurs besoins
des besoins les plus variés possibles
les et pour créer des ambiances les plus
variées possibles quand on part d'une
cour d'école de 2500 mètres carrés
entièrement en enrobé éventuellement
quand on a de la chance avec des arbres
évidemment on peut que faire mieux en
termes de de d'espace variés et donc
nous ce qu'on recherche c'est bien sûr
de répondre aux enjeux que sont de aux
besoins qui sont identifiés comme avoir
des besoins pour lire des besoins où on
est calme on observe quand même souvent
que les garçons jouent je vais faire un
peu vite mais les garçons sont au milieu
joue au ballon et puis les filles se
mettent autour quelle place et comment
on transforme et on bouleverse cette
organisation pour que les espaces soient
bien à tous etc donc en inventant aussi
d'autres façons d'organiser l'espace
on peut aussi réfléchir à aux
différentes sortes de manière de
s'asseoir par exemple les toutes les
postures possibles quand on est
adolescent en collège ou au lycée c'est
bien aussi un enjeu on est assis en
bande ensemble autour d'une table ou non
tout ça ce nous offre des possibilités
dans la palette aussi des usages
possibles pour les cours
[Applaudissements]
la cour d'école c'est bien sûr très on
l'a vu très technique on suit bien sûr
des phases de maîtrise d'oeuvre
classique et notre travail c'est bien de
développer l'ensemble des outils
graphiques pour exprimer le projet et ce
qu'on dit emmener les gens emmener les
acteurs dans cette histoire-là leur
laisser le temps aussi de se faire à la
transformation de cette cour qui
cristallise quand même beaucoup
d'habitudes et d'usages d'habitudes en
termes techniques d'habitude en termes
de règles entre le périscolaire et les
écoles par exemple donc on développe
tout un tas d'outils d'illustrations
pour présenter le projet la
transformation aux élus aux parents aux
élèves etc par exemple ici même pour moi
pour nous il ne peut pas y avoir de
restitution de transformation de cours
d'école sans que l'on soit revenu voir
les élèves pour leur dire comment leurs
paroles a été entendue par les adultes
qui ont pris les décisions et comment
voilà qu'est-ce qui a été retenu
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas été retenu donc là
par exemple on avait tout dessiné in
situ sur place pour présenter aux
enfants c'est aussi l'occasion aux élus
de dire combien ça coûte un projet un
tel projet et à quoi ça sert de payer
des impôts
et puis enfin c'est aussi l'occasion de
former les élus et de restituer le
projet aux élus donc de les inviter à
contribuer à participer à la plantation
ou autre et du coup de les former sur
ces questions de désimperméabilisation
on le voit bien dans on essaye là de
vous montrer toutes les peurs de la
transformation d'une cour d'école on est
bien au-delà de la simple végétalisation
on est bien au-delà de seulement poser
un bac potager puis un hôtel insectes
dans un coin l'objectif c'est bien de
transformer l'ensemble des usages et le
rapport entre chacun dans ses cours
d'école
alors pour le pour la dernière partie je
redonne la parole à Dani pour la
vraiment l'expertise des paysagistes
concepteurs qui est donc tout ce qui est
le vivant et le végétal oui en effet le
choix de la palette végétale c'est fait
partie vraiment de notre domaine
d'expertise je pense que voilà on est on
est à même en effet de d'évaluer cette
le choix c'est palettes selon les
différents les différents critères nous
disposons nous savons aujourd'hui qu'on
est ça devient très difficile de choisir
la palette végétale de demain avec ces
changements climatiques beaucoup de
plantes tombent malades deviennent
fragiles les boules dépérissent on a
énormément de de problématiques
sanitaires sur certains végétaux donc du
coup on nous on crée on est le lien avec
la filière du végétal à savoir les
pépiniérisme si les entreprises et
autres les producteurs de végétaux qui
eux ont des retours d'expérience sur
quel type de végétaux on fonctionne
selon les types de régions puisque bien
sûr nous avons également la spécificité
du sol du climat de chaque région et du
coup on s'appuie beaucoup sur cette
expertise pour pour choisir les types de
végétaux donc vous voyez il y a les
différents critères que l'on choisit
planter aussi aujourd'hui rafraîchir les
cours d'école plantés c'est aussi ça ne
fonctionne aussi que si on remet à jour
les différentes strates végétales à
savoir en nous avons en effet les arbres
pour les Francs des ombres mais il y a
aussi les échelles intermédiaires qu'on
a pu oublier pendant plusieurs décennies
depuis toujours la strate arbustive la
Strateur Bassée au sol qui eux apportent
de la diversité on veut aussi un support
de biodiversité d'éveil aussi se
retrouver aussi à la hauteur de l'enfant
donc c'est strates ces trois strates
sont vraiment primordiales pour avoir
des systèmes qui soient résilients par
rapport à ces phénomènes de fortes
chaleurs également qu'on subit de plus
en plus de plein fouet
là nous présenter un petit un exemple de
jardin d'insectes ça se situe en
Lorraine donc dans l'Est chez
Anne-Cécile et le choix c'est de mettre
en place des palettes végétales
méditerranéennes pour la Lorraine oui
aujourd'hui on peut le faire ça pose bon
voilà ça n'existe quand même des espaces
protégés mais l'idée c'est de pouvoir se
passer d'arrosage pour économiser les
ressources en eau petit détail il y a
pas longtemps j'apprenais que la palette
végétale méditerranéenne certes était
très résistante au réchauffement
climatique au phénomène de fortes
chaleurs en revanche elle n'apportait
pas forcément de fraîcheur au milieu
puisque le végétal méditerranéenaire si
je puis dire a tendance à fermer ses
sports justement garder sans son
humidité ne plus la restituer alors que
d'autres végétaux la restitue donc ça
veut dire aussi qu'il n'y a pas de
solution miracle qu'il faut vraiment
faire au cas par cas selon les besoins
selon les selon les
usages et selon la ressource
et enfin la petite illustration du
jardin potager de poche puisque en effet
il y a la question de du jardin potager
dans les cours d'école comme me disait
Edith que qu'est-ce qu'on en fait l'été
qui le gère
quels sont donc les comment dire les
ressources dont on dispose dans le
quartier avec dans les voilà au niveau
des agents avoir question ouverte
et petit mot juste de conclusion on sait
que c'est ce sont des investissements
très lourds pour les communes ces
transformations de cours d'école et on
voit bien aussi émerger l'intention de
certaines communes de vouloir ouvrir ces
espaces là comme espace public sur les
temps hors scolaires donc ça fait aussi
partie des réponses possibles aussi en
plein centre-ville ou autre alors tout
dépend des contextes mais c'est vrai que
c'est aussi une belle opportunité pour
les une belle opportunité pour les
communes de pouvoir offrir un nouvel
espace public frais pour les riverains
également
merci
merci beaucoup
on va passer maintenant aux échanges et
aux questions
qu'on pourrait
[Musique]
j'ai bien compris que c'était pas une
ZAC je voulais simplement savoir si
travailler de la même manière
au contraire c'est enfin c'est plutôt
des projets de reconquête et de et de
réamener des usages et de permettre de
nouveaux usages et justement
effectivement comme ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure de profiter et de faire
de ce projet de rénovation une
opportunité pour réinterroger l'ensemble
des usages et réintroduire la qualité de
sol de la biodiversité et l'ensemble de
ces sujets
moi j'aurais une question
savoir de votre expérience
lorsqu'on décide par exemple de vous
avez parlé de la concertation savoir qui
on avait autour de la table il y a les
élus locaux bon j'ai entendu aussi on
peut aller
mais c'est la place de l'éducation
nationale parce que moi j'ai un exemple
de d'établissement qu'on a souhaité
construire en disant attendez on fait
des salles de musique spéciale pour un
collège au moins que ça puisse être
ouvert à l'extérieur pour l'école de
musique plutôt quand même pendant tous
les temps les temps libres donc la
conception avait été un peu faite pour
qu'il y ait une entrée un peu séparée et
puis on s'aperçoit que l'éducation
nationale elle souhaite pas du tout pour
mettre les pieds dans un établissement
en dehors des des donc on a des secteurs
donc est-ce que dans les concertations
comment ça se passe vous avec
l'Éducation nationale pour vous c'est
représentants lorsqu'il y a comme ça
c'est con un petit peu alors ça va aussi
après sur les usages de de
d'alsh pour les écoles même les écoles
maternelles sur les équipements sportifs
enfin voilà on est dans
peut-être que Leslie pour en dire un mot
parce que elle elle mène des
concertations donc je pense que son
retour sera important ce que je peux
vous dire au niveau du Conseil de
l'Ordre et notamment aussi dans une
vision de la transition et d'amener des
bâtiments des carbonés nous on milite
beaucoup pour cette question de pouvoir
d'amener de nouveaux usages à
l'intérieur du bâtiment et ne pas le
limiter au strict usage pour lequel il
est fait ça s'est dit ouvrir les cours
d'école la mairie de Paris a annoncé que
elle allait en période de canicule
profitez de ses cours
ses cours oasis pour en faire profiter
tout le monde on sait aussi que dans les
milieux urbains très denses je reviens à
Paris parce que c'est un endroit que je
connais bien
les écoles peuvent être utilisées pour
des associations
des ateliers de peinture des ateliers de
de dessin hors période scolaires et donc
cette question de la mutualisation de
l'usage il est extrêmement important
parce que finalement il permet aussi de
mieux rentabiliser ça a été dit le
l'investissement lourd qui a été
consenti par la collectivité autour de
ce projet après
c'est un petit peu toute la question de
la rigidité des systèmes avec des
services de l'État qui sont sur des
sujets un peu doctrinaires parce que
vous parlez d'éducation nationale je
pense aussi que on peut parler du
ministère de l'intérieur avec tout ce
qui est approche anti attentats qui ont
extrêmement rigidité toutes les
séquences d'entrée autour des collèges
donc c'est effectivement des réalités
qui viennent impacter directement les
concepteurs que nous sommes qui viennent
apporter des contraintes qui se font
certainement au détriment d'un projet
qui se voudrait plus généreux plus
ouvert plus participatif
et
chaque là encore c'est chaque projet est
une négociation et je pense aussi que à
l'intérieur de la concertation il y a
aussi une grande dimension humaine et
donc ben il y a des services de l'État
qui se prêtent plus ou moins au jeu ou
qui prennent peut-être plus de latitude
et qui participent plus et qui
s'investissent plus parce que telle ou
telle personne
voilà
en tout cas pas je ne sais pas si à ma
connaissance il y a des directives
autour de cette question mais ça
pourrait être une question de dialogue
avec les les services de l'État pour
donner des directives pour aider que sur
les territoires c'est concertation soit
plus souple je sais pas si Leslie toi tu
as des choses à
est-ce que vous avez dans votre
conception la capacité de justement de
prendre en compte ce cahier des charges
je comprends moi il faut que ce soit à
la fois ouvert vers l'extérieur en même
temps suffisamment hermétique pour faire
des des protections enfin est-ce que
c'est vous avez des outils pour de toute
façon si vous voulez
comment dire la solution architecturale
donne une réponse au programme on
parlait tout à l'heure des usages qui
étaient pas forcément adaptés mais ces
questions de de contrôle d'accès de de
rigidité de certains points
effectivement c'est ça fait partie du
cahier des charges auquel on doit
répondre donc de toute façon le projet a
doit apporter une réponse après
le
dire quand on parle de sécurité et de
plan Vigipirate c'est sûr que bah les
réponses qu'on apporte sont moi
généreuses et moins en ouverture il y a
peut-être sa limite aussi le nombre
d'accès donc
des arbitrages et en même temps on
comprend aussi que
on voit pas dans le monde dans lequel on
vit aujourd'hui que l'éducation
nationale et le ministère de l'Intérieur
fasse l'impasse sur ces questions de
sécurité des enfants de la même façon
qu'il y a pas d'impasse sur la question
de la sécurité incendie donc c'est des
sujets si vous voulez qui
impacte la réponse architecturale à nous
de la rendre la plus qualitative
possible au cas par cas en fonction des
situations de la même façon et c'est là
aussi où je reviens à mon propos qui
était de dire que
on ne peut avoir que des solutions qui
sont au cas par cas puisque en fait une
réponse est pas du tout la même en
milieu urbain dense qu'en milieu rural
ou que dans une petite ville avec des
abords plus ou moins dégagés avec des
accès plus ou moins accessibles pour les
voitures enfin les voitures
tout ce qui est aménagement d'espace
public aussi des desserts de transport
tous ces sujets là entre en ligne de
compte
et au cas par cas on doit arbitrer sur
ces sujets peut-être Leslie tu peux
compléter je sais pas
merci je veux bien je voulais vous
raconter le fait qu'on a fait un petit
voyage à l'agence dans le Voralberg donc
en Autriche où on a rencontré des écoles
dont la cour était quasiment ouverte et
partagée sur la place du village donc et
en parallèle au même moment on décidé
une école où on était en plein
effectivement problématique attentat et
où on avait même plus le droit de Vitré
en fait entre le couloir et la salle de
classe pour que ça soit des salles de
classe refuge pour que les enfants
puissent se cacher donc on était dans
une véritablement dans deux mondes
distincts différents et ça crée pas du
tout spatialement les mêmes espaces
c'est pas pour autant que le groupe
scolaire que l'on a fait n'est pas
agréable en tout cas clairement il est
pas de la même façon en relation et les
enfants ne sont plus de la même façon en
relation avec
avec la ville parce qu'en fait on les
protège et on crée des murailles entre
guillemets ensuite sur la question pour
vous qui vous posiez monsieur le
Président sur la question de mais
finalement comment est-ce que finalement
ce corps enseignant va partager
participer
à ces échanges et va faire en sorte que
c'est ces écoles ne soient pas bloquées
en été par exemple ou bloquer le
week-end ou le soir et puis c'est avoir
mutualisation des espaces et des usages
de qui à mon avis est vraiment pertinent
et parce que au moins on fera des écoles
des lieux qui seront utilisés à plein de
moments et ça sera très avantageux mais
si effectivement dans ces alors moi
j'appelle pas ça des concertations qui
sont problématiques je pense moi
j'appelle ça plutôt des ateliers
participatifs parce que la grosse
différence c'est que la concertation va
être plutôt sur une dimension on va
présenter aux autres alors que les
ateliers participatifs on a tous
ensemble même sujet et on va tous
travailler autour de ce sujet et du coup
ça va donner des réponses c'est ça que
sur lequel vous pourriez avoir
finalement la main c'est en travaillant
sur aussi cette ces ateliers
participatifs même en amont du programme
et que ces ateliers participatifs
perdurent après le programme avec des
soit les architectes ou des ailes on les
appelle argent architectes assistant
pardon à maîtrise d'usage et le mot
d'ordre et de clés que j'entends depuis
tout à l'heure c'est cas par cas c'est
sur mesure c'est contextuel voilà et en
fait moi je suis persuadée que en binôme
et même un trinôme ingénieur architecte
paysagiste écologue
en fait vous aurez des projets
magnifiques cohérents si tous ces pois
sont pris en compte
juste peut-être une toute petite
précision le Conseil national en ce
moment travaille avec l'Éducation
nationale justement à l'élaboration et à
l'intégration des problématiques de
transition écologique à l'intérieur des
programmes c'est-à-dire que on voit bien
que
c'est la dichotomie c'est toujours la
même dichotomie française entre d'un
côté un législateur national et de
l'autre côté des territoires qui ont des
besoins spécifiques et des donc les
crispations elles sont souvent ici à
cette articulation entre les besoins des
territoires chacun à leur niveau et de
l'autre côté des directives nationales
donc
nous on travaille avec avec l'Éducation
nationale justement peut-être sur
l'élaboration des programmes et la mise
à jour de certaines recommandations mais
on pourrait encourager effectivement
qu'il y ait des réflexions qui soient
plus locales qui permettent d'intégrer
alors il y a aussi des démarches locales
je passe je pense aux démarches bâtiment
durables mais qui sont des formes de
certification et d'accompagnement de
projets justement qui sont basés sur des
référentiels plutôt locaux et il y a
peut-être il y a peut-être des réponses
et des solutions dans des écosystèmes
qui sont plus régionaux que des
écosystèmes nationaux donc là aussi
c'est la question du positionnement on a
je vous parlais de comment je vous
parlais de patrimoine
tout à l'heure il y a un petit peu les
mêmes questionnements avec les archers
avec des bâtiments de France et une
parole de l'État qui est un peu
monocorde qui a du mal à se faire à la
question de de l'adaptation
et justement des réponses qui doivent
être adaptées donc pareil une sur ces
sujets on travaille là avec le ministère
de la culture et les acheter des
bâtiments de France justement pour un
peu
et arrêter d'être dans des injonctions
contradictoires en fait je pense que le
plus compliqué c'est l'injonction
contradictoire et il faut vraiment que
les services de l'État et en même temps
les territoires tout le monde œuvre à la
même dynamique en fait voilà juste
concernant les espaces extérieurs la
collaboration avec le corps enseignant
que ce soit dans des collèges ou dans
des des écoles primaires se fait plutôt
bien parce que les enseignants avec
justement la crise du covid est très
demande enfin le corps enseignant et
très demandeur de faire classe dehors
par contre c'est vrai que c'est
important vraiment une transformation ne
peut pas se faire sans ces personnes
sans les enseignants sans le personnel
aussi du périscolaire parce que c'est
personne ont des habitudes aussi et
elles ont des exigences aussi en termes
de surveillance un enfant a besoin
d'être surveillé mais les enseignants
sur leur temps de récréation ont besoin
aussi de veiller à la sécurité donc d'où
aussi l'implication nécessaire
que souvent nous a dit les enfants
veulent des accrobranches évidemment ce
n'est pas possible ce n'est pas le rôle
les enseignants de surveiller de la
croix blanche ni des des jeux trop
dangereux donc il y a un équilibre à
trouver vraiment fin et on l'a vu pour
des collèges par exemple des enseignants
qui se sont aussi
investis pour la demande de faire de
faire de l'extérieur un réel support
pédagogique pour la météo lire l'heure
la pluviométrie faire de la dissection
de certains végétaux qui nous ont
demandé à intégrer dans la palette
végétale etc ça c'est c'est des clés qui
nous semblent être absolument nécessaire
que nous concepteurs on ne peut pas
imposer on l'a par exemple dans un
collège je pense on va mettre un
poulailler moi j'ai je me suis dit qu'à
un moment quelqu'un va tiquer il va nous
dire non finalement le met plus non non
ils y tiennent l'ensemble du personnel
tient à la présence de ces animaux dans
la cour etc donc je crois que quand ils
sont impliqués dès le début alors ça
crée des espaces enfin c'est un
potentiel extraordinaire pour créer des
espaces qui répondent à de nombreux
besoins
moi je pense aussi
dans cette collège qui habite donc il y
a un concierge là qui reste tout l'été
je pense aussi et je pense que ça aussi
été dit en filigrane sur les questions
de
concertation je pense que ces moments de
transformation que ce soit des espaces
extérieurs ou que ce soit les bâtiments
c'est aussi le moment
d'avoir une approche pédagogique si vous
voulez un bâtiment et un chantier c'est
quand même un support pédagogique génial
et une cour d'école qui se transforme
donc c'est aussi parler du cycle de
l'eau parler de la question de la
transition écologique parler de la
consommation énergétique pourquoi c'est
important de de préserver les
consommations la consommation
énergétique ça ça amène aussi des
interrogations sur sur l'économie sur
l'argent sur le rapport à l'argent
en bâtiment il y a tout le champ de la
physique la statique comprend une
structure pourquoi ça en collège c'est
plutôt que d'avoir un cours de physique
essayer de comprendre ce que c'est
qu'une charpente c'est des donc c'est il
y a aussi
cette idée je reviens à l'idée de
l'opportunité de de faire que tout ce
temps de la transformation soit aussi
intempédagogique et pour avoir un temps
pédagogique on a besoin des enseignants
dans un des collèges on a installé des
des éléments qui permettent de mesurer
la consommation du bâtiment lui-même
donc c'est à dire que les élèves peuvent
c'est aussi intéressant elles peuvent
observer combien le bâtiment consomme au
moment des
je voudrais
me mettre à la place et ça m'est pas
difficile parce que j'étais exécutif
départemental donc je sais ce qu'il en
est
de tous les maîtres d'ouvrage que vous
rencontrez à l'occasion de ces projets
quelles sont les préoccupations première
du mode d'ouvrage
d'abord parce que l'éducation nationale
prend quand même une distance
stratégique par rapport au maître
d'ouvrage
elle ne veut pas que on puisse lui faire
le grillage d'avoir eu tel ou tel
desiderata elle va se contenter de voir
l'aspect enseignement et l'aspect
sécurité des enfants et il est rare
d'ailleurs que les
l'éducation nationale soit totalement
associée
au projet sinon pour quand on a le
travail qui a été fait par la maîtrise
d'oeuvre pour
voir si effectivement ces préoccupations
de sécurité de qualité d'enseignement de
qualité de d'accueil des enfants sont
remplis
donc
ceci étant posé le maître d'ouvrage lui
il va d'abord
il faut savoir qu'un collège pour
mettons 400 400 élèves 500 élèves c'est
aujourd'hui
à peu près une vingtaine de millions
d'euros donc c'est pour un pour une
collectivité comme un département ça
fait déjà beaucoup sur un département
comme le mien il y a 36 collèges publics
et malheureusement ils sont pas tous
sont parfait état et si on peut pas
reconstruire à neuf mais même quand on
fait ce qui arrive souvent des
rénovations de collège ce sont également
des chantiers très importants et donc là
la préoccupation du maître d'ouvrage ça
va être comme un petit peu le même souci
que l'éducation nationale c'est d'abord
assurer s'assurer de d'un accueil qui
permette un enseignement dans les
meilleures conditions possibles de
l'élève en respectant ce que sont
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
les conditions posées par l'État
notamment quand l'État ce qui est ce qui
est rare sur des établissements comme le
collège c'est plutôt la collectivité
départementale qui qui prend en général
tout le paiement de l'outil mais
l'État va quand même être très attentif
à ce que les règles de sécurité
notamment vous évoquez Vigipirate et
notamment les obligations qui ont été
faites aux établissements scolaires de
ce chlore
de ne pas permettre ni l'entrée de
personnes extérieures ni la sortie des
élèves avec des clés
si quelqu'un doit entrer qui n'est pas
un habitué de la maison il va d'objet de
montrer pas de Blanche donc ça c'est ça
sera exigé ça me paraît normal alors on
peut trouver peut-être dans le milieu
primaire élémentaire des endroits où
finalement les élèves ne sont pas très
nombreux ou le lieu est clos et où on
peut faire un certain nombre de choses
mais dans un collège à partir de
quelques centaines d'élèves c'est
extrêmement difficile et quel que soit
d'ailleurs même s'il y a des zones plus
sensibles que d'autres même dans une
ville normale il y a toujours des
dangers on peut se faire un gosse qui se
fait écraser par une voiture
c'est arrivé donc voilà donc
le financement ensuite il va chercher un
site si c'est si c'est une construction
neuve un site qui
remplit les conditions d'accès parce
qu'il y a des problèmes d'accès mais il
y a aussi des problèmes de de l'une de
vous évoquez tout à l'heure les
distances qui peut y avoir dans
l'organisation territoriale du
territoire et là
en général les collèges vous parlent de
36 collèges chez moi il y a des gros
collèges des petits collèges mais ce
sont des collèges qui étaient autrefois
au siège de ce qui était ce qu'il est
plus le cas le siège du chef-lieu de
canton je fais lieux de canton bon là on
est à la campagne même si quelquefois il
y a 500 habitants ça peut être un
chef-lieu de canton et il y aura pas
forcément de collège mais le collège
sera un petit collège bon tout ça va
compter et j'ai un exemple récent dans
mon département où la personne qui m'a
succédé à la présence du département à
voulu lancer un plan collège 2050 et
elle a commencé à évoquer c'est une
jeune femme
les possibilités de changement de
fermeture éventuelle c'était la
révolution donc tout ça pour dire que je
vous écoutais tout à l'heure je trouve
que ce que vous présentez c'est un c'est
un monde merveilleux pour accueillir les
enfants mais je crois que vous aurez si
vous présentez cela à part peut-être
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il y a certains
élus qui se sentent capables de pouvoir
assumer le rôle de d'élus et de
responsable autrement mais ce sera
difficile parce que pour l'élu c'est sa
responsabilité qui est en jeu
y compris avec une poule qui peut piquer
la main d'un gamin parce que ça pique
bien une poule quand ça pique et où donc
voilà excusez mon je suis c'est un une
vision très terre à terre des choses
mais qui qui est un petit peu celle que
vous allez trouver souvent quand on va
vous faire une proposition de maîtrise
d'ouvrage de maîtrise d'oeuf pardon on
va peut-être enchaîner plusieurs
questions voilà parce qu'il y en a qui
se complètent d'ailleurs avec
merci merci
d'exemple les expériences que vous avez
donné parce que c'est très intéressant
et c'est vrai que ça ouvre je sais pas
si c'est un monde merveilleux mais ça
ouvre de belles perspectives je vais
être aussi un peu terre à terre mais
le la somme globale de rénovation du
bâti scolaire a été évaluée à 40
milliards
et vous avez vous-même évoqué
l'éventualité de désert architecturaux
donc quand on met bout à bout les sommes
en jeu et les personnes en situation
de travail sur cette rénovation
énergétique à quelle échéance vous
imaginez qu'on puisse répondre
au quasi obligations qui sont celles de
la France aujourd'hui première question
deuxième question vous avez évoqué un
travail mené en collaboration avec
l'Éducation nationale et lors des
architectes
rassurez-moi mais c'est pas vous qui
êtes en cause mais rassurez-moi est-ce
que les collectivités sont associées à
ce travail là parce qu'effectivement que
ce soit les écoles élémentaires et
maternel c'est du ressort des communes
les collèges des départements les lycées
les régions et donc l'éducation
nationale peut bien décider de tout ce
qu'elle veut au final c'est quand même
les collectivités qui vont financer tout
cela et il me semble que ce serait utile
qu'elle soit dans la boucle dès le début
pour
est-ce que pardon
oui c'est ça non mais je dis pas qu'il
faut non plus évacuer l'éducation
nationale mais il y a besoin que ces
trois acteurs au moins et vous vous en
mettez davantage encore autour de la
table et c'est ça qui est intéressant
puisse avoir une réflexion globale et en
amont
qu'est-ce que est-ce que vous avez parce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un petit
fléchissement démographique en termes
d'élèves et ça donne lieu à ou des
regroupements d'écoles ou à des
fermetures de collège dans certains
endroits quel regard vous vous avez de
ces mouvements là qui peuvent parce
qu'on a parfois l'expérience de
mouvement qui paraissent pertinent à
l'instant T puis 10 ans ou 15 ans après
on se dit bah c'est peut-être pas ça
qu'il aurait fallu faire donc quel est
votre regard là dessus et puis dernier
truc mais alors là vraiment très très
compliqué de rénover un bâtiment
scolaire
occupé
et donc il y a un vrai enjeu il me
semble à côté ce qu'on fait des
rénovations qui peuvent parfois être
très lourdes et donc est-ce que vous
avez aussi des exemples réussis si
possible de rénovation dans des il y en
a non je sais qu'il y en a mais c'est
quand même un sacré casse-tête
je vais compléter là-bas d'abord on a
une illustration
le Sénat dispose là dans la cour de
bâtiments modulaire on voit qu'on peut
arriver à faire enfin moi j'ai vu
l'école complète avec dans les
modulaires qui
non mais
qui sont parfois tellement bien qu'après
les gens veulent pas quitter le
modulaire mais
moi je complète juste est-ce que vous
disposez d'une évaluation du coût par
mètre carré de la rénovation énergétique
des différents types de bâtiments ou par
rapport à leur construction ex nihilo ou
et pareil pour l'aménagement des cours
extérieurs et puis tout dernier point
aussi on a parlé donc des effectifs des
40 milliards mais est-ce qu'en raison
de l'ampleur des travaux est-ce qu'on
d'après vous vous ressentez qu'on est
assez d'entreprise sur le territoire
pour pouvoir répondre à ses besoins sous
quel délai
aujourd'hui quels sont les collèges qui
sont dans les situations dégradées et
vers ou orienter parce que il y a les 40
milliards de la rénovation scolaires les
choses qui passent les 100 milliards et
700 000 rénovations de permis de
logement pour lutter contre la
difficulté énergétique ménage et qui
sont sollicités sur les mêmes
professions qui sont les concepteurs et
sur les questions des entreprises et
justement là
on a participé au Conseil national de la
restauration de logement et là aussi on
plaide pour avoir un plan
d'investissement
stratégique à 5 ans ou à 10 ans pour
donner de la visibilité
et pour permettre aux filières de
s'organiser et de monter en puissance
pour répondre justement à cet enjeu et
commencer là où finalement c'est le plus
dur et c'est le plus urgent et peut-être
laisser de côté des bâtiments qui ont
été construits il y a 20 ans avec où il
y avait déjà des réglementations
thermiques ou ont commencé à se
préoccuper de ces sujets là donc on est
problème de maintenance effectivement
mais qui pourrait se permettre
d'attendre cinq ans alors que les les
collèges des années 70-80 qui ont des
grandes façades très plein sud eux
peuvent pas se permettre ça donc il y a
la question d'une vision stratégique
donc du recueil de données
là pour le coup national et centralisé
avec couplé à un plan d'investissement à
5 ou 10 ans pour donner aux filières des
visibilités et des possibilités de
s'organiser ça c'est hyper important et
moi j'ai même au-delà de ça on appelle
aussi à ce que dans cette question de la
visibilité
il y a des échos conditionnalités
pour permettre aussi à des filières
biosourcés géosourcés réemploi
localement de s'organiser pour répondre
notamment avec une commande publique
exemplaire c'est-à-dire que si dans les
40 milliards on exige que y est x% de
matériaux et employés de matériaux
biosourcés et que ces éléments-là sont
répartis sur la base du plan de charge
effectivement ça permet à des filières
de se projeter et de s'investir donc
cette visibilité des personnes privées
elle est elle est hyper importante et
elle est vraiment essentielle
pour répondre à vos préoccupations de
d'avoir une vision qui soit monsieur
Favreau vous nous disiez on vous
présente un monde idéal et on est
peut-être à côté des préoccupations
première d'un maître d'ouvrage moi j'ai
un petit peu envie de vous dire
au travers des procédures que met en
place le maître d'ouvrage il a aussi les
moyens quand on dépose quand on dépense
20 millions d'euros pour pour faire une
réhabilitation on peut aussi donner les
moyens
oui mais en réab c'est un sujet pour que
quand l'ariabe est un petit peu
ambitieuse c'est peut-être pas 20
millions mais c'est quand même des
budgets qui sont conséquents et je pense
que
j'en reviens moi à la procédure et au
choix des équipes et et au choix du cas
par cas c'est-à-dire que je pense que
pour le coup là aussi la commande
publique elle peut se elle devrait
s'appliquer des objectifs d'exemplarité
éventuellement quand il y a des sujets
un peu complexes pourquoi pas aller au
concours même si c'est pas obligatoire
même si mais ça permet aussi
d'éclairer d'avoir le choix entre
plusieurs sujets alors effectivement
c'est une procédure d'attribution qui
est qui est plus coûteuse mais ça permet
je pense une ciné
d'emporter de façon plus simple
l'ensemble de de la de l'écosystème qui
a qui est attaché au projet parce que on
part on choisit un projet et on se
limite pas à une équipe et et ça
renforce en fait le plaidoyer que je
faisais tout à l'heure sur éviter les
contrats globaux et plutôt être sur de
la maîtrise d'ouvrage de la maîtrise
d'oeuvre classique pour avoir une
approche justement au cas par cas et qui
est plus concerté et avec des procédures
de désignation qui peuvent aller
jusqu'au concours
et qui permet de résoudre à mon avis
tout un tas de problèmes en amont
sur des questions de d'adéquation entre
d'un côté le programme et de l'autre
côté la solution architecturale qui est
des entreprises générales
dans les collèges dans ma région qui
sont des collèges sur des zones plutôt
rurales
il y a toujours un maître d'oeuvre et il
y a les corps de métier qui
interviennent derrière se mettre
d'oeuvre donc on a
là-dessus on a une vision qui est
pluriel de de ce que peut concevoir tel
ou tel architecte je vais dire trois ou
quatre architectes à la sortie sur le
concours qui reste
je pense beaucoup au contrat globaux
avec engagement surperformance où là
vous êtes en conception réalisation ou
l'équipe de maîtrise d'oeuvre n'est plus
en lien direct avec sa maîtrise
d'ouvrage puisque elle est noyée dans un
groupement où il y a une entreprise qui
pilote des entreprises de maintenance
derrière et la maîtrise d'oeuvre du coup
qui est séparée de la maîtrise d'ouvrage
et qui est plus justement à côté d'elle
en conseil
pour défendre ses intérêts c'est un
petit peu la limite du contrat global et
c'est c'est plutôt à ce sujet là après
que les travaux soient réalisés en
entreprise générale ou pas je pense que
c'est un autre sujet la question elle
est d'éviter le conception réa pour pour
amener je pense plus de qualité
représenté par par la FFP on vous a mis
aussi le la gouvernance vertueuse voilà
idéale
je sais plus si on peut la projeter
encore je crois que les slides sont
partis mais vous avez le document de
travail en deux trois mots voilà je
voulais en effet à titre d'exemple vous
présenter une gouvernance qui nous
qualifie vraiment de vertueuse pour les
courbisonnière de la ville de Bordeaux
puisqu'il faut savoir que la maîtrise
ouvrages donc c'est la DAE la direction
des équipements d'animation d'éducation
c'est la ville de Bordeaux il y a un
pilotage qui est porté par le pôle
patrimoine végétal et biodiversité c'est
Bordeaux métropole mais c'est aussi en
quelque sorte le gestionnaire des
espaces verts si je puis dire il y a une
équipe d'assistance à maîtrise d'ouvrage
avec le bureau d'études alto step
ingénierie environnement et des
paysagistes n'ont nous-mêmes et ensuite
ils font appel à quatre équipes de
maîtrise d'oeuvre voilà c'est un marché
avec quatre équipes de maîtrise d'oeuvre
donc le paysagiste est mandataire
et ensuite il y a tout un partenariat
avec les acteurs locaux qui se fait la
concertation et aussi beaucoup beaucoup
d'échanges une application avec les avec
tous les partenaires donc ça c'est pour
vous poser le cadre la volonté politique
est très claire c'est vrai que c'est
l'avantage comme vous disiez les les
groupes scolaires les crèches c'est plus
c'est vrai que c'est peut-être plus
facile à gérer puisque bah du coup on a
une volonté politique qui consiste à
désimperméabiliser végétaliser les cours
d'école et
amener l'inclusivement l'inclusion aussi
fille garçon dans les cours
ce qu'on a remarqué en effet c'est des
problèmes de surcoût qui sont arrivés
avec les aléas bon ça c'est c'est
malheureusement le propre du projet à
savoir quand même que le les travaux de
des imperméabilisés de désabusa bien
mobilisation pardon Edith lui disait
tout à l'heure c'est quand même des
travaux très lourds et c'est quasiment
40% du monde de l'enveloppe globale des
travaux donc un pan négliger puisque
après il faut végétaliser derrière cela
pour la ville de Bordeaux est-ce qu'il
m'a ce qu'ils ont fait pour les cours
buissonnières ils ont lancé les marchés
de travaux sur quatre ans d'un coup avec
les BPU qui sont sortis là ils ont
consulté des entreprises donc entreprise
d'espace vert VRD et mobilier également
et il s'avère qu'en effet comme vous
disiez il y a pas beaucoup les
entreprises répondent mais c'est
difficile vu la pression de ce timing
très court en été trouvé des entreprises
capables de se mobiliser sur un temps
aussi court et avec les compétences
puisque on a bien sûr toutes les
problématiques possibles et imaginables
si t'occuper ou pas pour les matiques
d'accès problématique voilà de bruit
aussi dans certains cas et donc voilà
donc il y a donc du coup un projet
banquier heureusement porté par les élus
avec les ce que ça peut engendrer en
effet comme comme plus value si je puis
dire et voilà et qu'est-ce que je peux
conclure voilà je voulais juste signaler
en
du coup vous aviez posé la question de
comment on peut répondre à cette demande
donc nous paysagiste on est quand même
formé aussi du cet exemple dans le donc
c'est porté par le sérieux 54 donc
Meurthe-et-Moselle aussi qui monte des
formations sur la facilitation de groupe
notamment aussi et qui nous fait monter
aussi en compétences sur comment on
accompagne aussi ces situations dans la
résolution de projet dans la résolution
de problèmes etc et comment on emmène
l'ensemble de ces acteurs dans leur
diversité vers quelque chose de commun
et de constructif donc on est formé
vraiment sur ces sur ces questions là
par contre on l'a dit il faut pas
négliger le temps nécessaire à ça une
cour d'école moi quand on m'appelle en
janvier pour me dire on veut que les
travaux commencent en juillet je leur
dis ben on va passer son tour parce que
c'est pas possible on peut pas faire des
études avec mené au lance-pierre il nous
faut du temps et il faut surtout du
temps à la communauté éducative ou aux
collectivités pour cheminer vers le la
transformation ça veut dire quand on
transforme une cour d'école ou de
collège il faut s'assurer aussi que
derrière les services techniques sont en
accord aussi avec
la charge potentiellement supplémentaire
aussi d'entretien et de gestion donc ça
demande du temps ça ne peut pas se faire
en six mois ça je ce n'est pas possible
et plus pour moi on prend ce temps là on
le voit vraiment on commence à avoir
plein d'exemples menés au sein de
l'agence ou de collègues
plus on prend le temps plus les projets
sont réussis en fait je crois que c'est
vraiment un gage de qualité alors certes
il y a beaucoup de cours d'école d'école
mais on est en capacité de pouvoir y
répondre alors c'est vrai que pour les
cours d'école ça peut être parfois
dissocié aussi du bâtiment donc il peut
y avoir des contrats aussi de gré à gré
aussi qui peuvent se faire ou donc c'est
peut-être moins lourd en termes de
marché en tout cas de maîtrise d'oeuvre
et c'est vrai que la question de par
exemple moi je vais parler de la Moselle
c'est vrai que dès qu'on a des cours
d'école on a l'agence de lorameuse qui
finance qui a vraiment un très gros fort
programme sur le programme de école
bulle nature ce qui a généré une forte
demande et donc les entreprises
clairement quand elles ont une ou deux
écoles l'été leur planning et il est
bouquet quoi donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut calibrer aussi nos démarrages de
missions en temps et en heure et ça veut
dire que les maîtrises d'ouvrage doivent
être formées aussi et anticipées cette
notion-là de ben non on se réveille pas
en janvier pour une rénovation l'été ce
n'est pas possible donc mais ça ça se
fait
allez-y
merci beaucoup moi je rejoins vraiment
tout ce qui a été dit je voulais
répondre à Madame sur la question des 40
milliards les sommes qui sont
importantes
c'est vrai que la France a beaucoup
d'obligations et là où je rejoins des
collègues c'est sur l'idée que peut-être
qu'on va prendre 6 mois de plus à
réaliser concertation en tout cas elle
sera fait en relation avec les
véritables besoins locaux ce qui fait
que derrière qu'en fait on va avoir le
projet qui va énergie par exemple
complètement aux attentes des besoins et
du coup mon investit plus pour 5-10 ans
l'investit 30 ans sur une observation
qui est efficace il faut pas partir du
principe de
d'imposer en fait des extensions avec un
process industriel qui sera toujours le
même parce que ça va répondre à pas aux
problématiques locales on l'a dit
plusieurs fois et ensuite ce n'est pas
du tout une autobi tout ce qu'on est en
train de dire tous les jours nous
construisons en bois en paille en terre
crue dans les budgets qui sont alloués
nous y arrivons sans problème ça nous
avons une démarche frugale de sobriété
des projets très doux très esthétiques
très bien accueilli donc je crois pas de
quoi on parle dans cette utopie là au
contraire sachez que la dernière usine
que l'on vient de livrer à Nîmes
l'isolant biosourcée était moins cher
que l'isolant minéral donc les
changements sont en train de se faire
très largement il faut aussi savoir que
la filière qu'on avait choisi est
déterminée au départ c'était la paille
de la paille de riz est en train de
s'effondrer on n'a pas pu le faire en
main de vie ça veut dire que si vous ne
vous rendez pas compte que des filières
sont en train de s'écouler qu'il faut
les soutenir parce que c'est notre
avenir c'est ça qui va être compliqué
donc vraiment on
vous encourage à trouver
en fait c'est les rénovations et
peut-être que les finitions telles que
la peinture pourrait pourquoi pas être
envisagée
par dans un second temps peut-être qu'on
pourrait livrer des choses un peu moins
abouties qui réduirait un peu le goût
financier peut-être que les parents
pourraient aussi participer ça
recréerait du lien avec les acteurs pour
dire que les parents rentreraient dans
l'école
un certain moment il faut trouver des
solutions alternatives pour ne peut-être
pas tout financer d'un coup mais en tout
cas quand on fait quelque chose on le
fait bien
alors moi je voulais vous rassurer aussi
madame sur ce travail qu'on fait avec
l'Éducation nationale et ne pas créer de
problèmes là il y en a pas en fait c'est
plus justement c'est je reviens à cette
cette dichotomie entre d'un côté des
injonctions nationales et de l'autre
côté à une réalité terrain on travaille
le travail qu'on fait c'est plutôt
travailler à des référentiels du coup à
marquer
il y a des choses là dont on n'a pas du
tout parlé mais on parle pas du tout de
renouvellement d'air de donc des
référentiels qui donnent des obligations
concepteur pour une classe de 30 élèves
on doit avoir telle renouvellement d'air
on doit assurer tel qu'ils sont des
choses qui aujourd'hui
et encore des choses qui échappent à la
réglementation la réglementation
thermique sur le bâtiment tertiaire
justement elle a tout un pont de
prescription autour de la ventilation
qui sont qui qui disent qui font
référence à ce référentiel qui a
travaillé avec l'Éducation nationale
donc il y a il y a toujours cette
question d'une d'obligation parce que je
veux dire l'état aussi la responsabilité
de l'État c'est aussi de garantir que
chaque élève à n'importe quel endroit du
territoire a accès à des conditions
avec un une exigence de qualité qui est
homogène donc il y a il faut toujours
jouer de cette
là encore c'est pas de l'injonction
qu'on tradictoire mais c'est toujours
entre
une obligation de résultat national pour
que chacun ait accès à une école dans le
des meilleurs conditions et localement
l'adaptation au conseil ce territorial à
la volonté politique des élus je pense
que c'est extrêmement important aussi de
dire que dans cette question de la
transition c'est la puissance publique
n'est pas moteur et ne donne pas à elle
les les
objectifs de la qualité
ce sera ce sera difficile aussi derrière
aux équipes techniques de s'engager il
faut il faut voir que là on est aussi
dans un dans tout un processus de
transformation et ça a été très bien dit
par les paysagistes ou quand on fait des
cours d'école différente ou même quand
on fait des bâtiments frugaux ça c'est
ça demande aux utilisateurs aussi
d'avoir d'adapter leur comportement et
toutes ces questions de de
concertation elles sont là aussi pour
amener les gens à la transformation des
comportements et du coup je reviens à
cette question de la volonté politique
en amont tous ces projets il faut bien
que que les élus locaux et que il y a
une impulsion politique pour dire oui on
veut se donner les moyens d'aller vers
des projets les plus ambitieux possible
des projets très frugaux qui voir à
énergie positive
qui respecteront les problématiques
aussi disons artificialisation nette qui
amélioreront la qualité du traitement de
l'eau et tout ça mais ça si les élus que
vous êtes sont pas derrière nous pour
nous pour nous nous donner des exigences
qui soient à la hauteur des enjeux
c'est difficile pour nous aussi parce
que
changer c'est compliqué pour tout le
monde à tous les niveaux
y compris pour les équipes techniques et
y compris pour les gens qui qui font les
programmes qui qui comment qui
choisissent les maîtrises d'oeuvre qui
qui choisissent les processus les
processus de désignation
enfin je veux dire je parlais de
concours je reviens à cette question de
concours c'est plus compliqué ça coûte
plus cher de faire un concours mais en
même temps ça a beaucoup d'intérêt
beaucoup davantage et ça ça vous amène
aussi vers un choix qui sera plus
qualitatif voilà se donner des objectifs
sur les cours d'école j'entends je veux
je complète aussi votre propos sur le
fait que quand on nous quels sont les
intentions des maîtrises d'ouvrage moi
sincèrement dans tous les programmes
auxquels on répond il y a vraiment une
réelle intention bien sûr d'économie à
trouver pour déconnecter les autres
pluies en déconnecter les autres pluies
ça veut dire diminuer le volume d'eau
dans les réseaux publics donc ça veut
dire moins de gestion derrière donc les
collectivités sont motivés à ça bien sûr
donc il y a déjà cette première
intention et puis la deuxième qui arrive
ou peut-être même aller à égalité j'en
sais rien mais c'est le besoin
d'épanouissement des enfants demander à
n'importe quel instit qui surveille une
cour qui est réaménagée ce n'est plus du
tout la même ambiance il ne se passe
plus les mêmes choses il y a beaucoup
moins de conflits les enfants sont
répartis partout ils sont pas rentables
à se disputés sur le ballon etc ça
implique ça impose tout le monde aussi
dans une nouvelle on s'interroge à
nouveau sur nos pratiques ok on a
toujours fait comme ça pourquoi c'est
foot tous les midis mais en fait
peut-être qu'on pourrait organiser les
choses différemment juste le fait de
transformer les lieux implique un
induisent une une transformation aussi
des habitudes donc c'est un bien-être
aussi vraiment pour chacun en fait donc
je crois que la la plus-value elle est
vraiment là derrière que ce soit pour
l'intérieur ou l'extérieur je pense que
le mieux vivre dans ces espaces-là qui
sont le la première maison notre
première maison on apprend je crois que
c'est vraiment ça l'enjeu et c'est pas
du tout utopique je pense que c'est
vraiment partagé nous on le voit
vraiment au quotidien que ce soit dans
des villes ou dans des villages c'est
vraiment ce qu'on entend en premier je
pense que c'est c'est vraiment important
question
c'était plutôt mon expérience d'ancien
maire d'une commune de Sam 000 habitants
puisque j'entendu parler de construction
structure bois et isolation paille j'ai
construit comme ça une cantine scolaire
de 340 m² entièrement en structure bois
et isolation paille et aujourd'hui je
trouve pas
ma cantine voilà l'hiver c'est pas la
peine voilà ça ça reste assez donc voilà
c'est plutôt mon expérience de d'ancien
maire et en ce moment on rénove le
collège du pont de bois bien sûr il faut
se donner le temps ça vous avez raison
ça a mis au moins 5 ans avant de pouvoir
prendre une décision parce qu'il y a la
sécurité derrière tout ça comment faire
sortir les enfants surtout que tout
autour il y a une école élémentaire
maternelle et primaire donc il a fallu
prendre en compte tout ça donc faut
savoir aussi se laisser le temps avant
de comment dire de faire un projet et je
rejoins ma collègue c'est vrai que
parfois c'est compliqué parce que ben ça
met du temps il faut plus d'un an un an
et demi pour pour rénover le collège et
il y a le bruit il y a tout ça à penser
et c'est pas toujours évident en tout
cas quelques constructions bois et
isolation paille moi j'ai fait venir mes
collègues pour voir cette cantine on a
mis des hublots pour que les gamins
puissent voir qu'il y avait de la paille
et ça au niveau pédagogique c'est c'est
vraiment génial enfin voilà moi je garde
une expérience en tout cas de ce projet
extraordinaire
bien
écoutez
très enrichissant
on voit bien que nous renvoyer nos
propres responsabilités
ce qui est souvent le cas mais merci en
tout cas pour ces perspectives même si
on vous a demandé des réponses écrites
sur le chiffre quand même un petit peu
on aimerait bien avoir des choses un peu
plus concrètes sur
sur les coups vraiment c'est important
OK
ils sont indicatifs bien sûr
se permet aussi ok merci beaucoup en
tout cas